let me ask you the first time you
experienced being shot at how was that
you know who find his llama saying do
you know how many how much money hundred
bill dollars in the boxes dope tougher
back I seen it but I couldn't touch it
it would say a private so soldier let me
ask if you ever want to get married and
have kids and have a family yeah of
course
never become special forces if I was
caught away we both was dead I tried to
land it in the grass I couldn't make it
I said God we're gonna die
[Music]
so look many of you have watched a movie
a team or some of you back in the days
used to watch this series called a team
it was fascinating these were like super
soldiers going out there there were
heroes there were rock stars but then
there's a real-life 18 which is the man
I'm sitting next to right now he was
part of the a-team he was not only
special forces in us that he sort of 24
years with a lot of experience he had
his own story of Black Hawk Down which
we'll get into which the pilot died and
some of the stories you'll even see some
of the pictures here
he had experiences with Somalia he had
experiences all over the world but he
was Special Forces in Iran during the
Shahs era which is pretty wild for him
to go from there to be in Special Forces
in u.s. black belt so many different
angles we're gonna go with the story but
with that being said we have a hero here
today with us Oh hiya changies lahee gee
thank you very much thank you so much
for being a guest on value tamer thank
you my pleasure thank you so much you
brought me here is honored to be here
thank you I think the the feelings all
here because for me you know when I'm in
the Army and I'm an e4 and I remember I
was at three to six engineers which it
was a unit at Fort Campbell Kentucky and
I was a Hummer mechanic and I used to go
and work out at this gym in the Fort
Campbell calls east step it was a main
gym at work Campbell right and I would
get to talk to the Special Forces gun
and all of a sudden one guy said hey you
speak all the languages have you ever
thought about it then my unit we started
to talk when I said hey come and come
and sit down at the fifth group we maybe
become an 18 Delta then we had that
conversation and I was gonna go that
direction the reason why I share this
story with you it's every time I would
see the Special Forces badge or the
Rangers badge it was like you're sitting
down with a hero in the arms so the fact
that you're sitting next to me and
you're from Iran I'm so looking forward
to this anyway I couldn't put this book
down we're on a flight I'm reading it
tomorrow you're mars-like oh my gosh no
way yes so many great things in this
book we're gonna leave the link below
for you to be able to get the book as
well but prior to getting to all these
stories why don't we go all the back
to Iran's okay you were raised in Iran
right outside of Tehran I think was like
50 miles 50 kilometers outside of Tehran
but I kind of want to go and you know
talk about your experiences there and
your upbringing in your father your
family and how you got into the military
Ron so let's start off their first sure
I born in Tehran as you said sort off
their own so my dad when he was it was
pretty a smart guy when he was 16 years
old he was mayor of north of tehran
Chevron 16 years old it was yes he was
amazing he was amazing guy I couldn't
believe it and he's writing speaking so
well even he did not finish the college
I went to 12 years school it was pretty
small right Oh unbelievable so boring
Tehran and my dad got job in Ubud on so
when I was five years old we moved over
Don and my dad got job in police
department in Abadan is the number one
oil refinery in the world that correct
which people live there was a very
beautiful right it's very likely a lens
type of that's correct that's correct so
us we were there since I was seven eight
years old always want to come to America
as you know in Iran before eighteen
years old
you cannot get out unless you serve the
military he is a drafted it's not just
like a u.s. wall until so I went to
finish my another three three and a half
years from abadan we'll move it to
Tehran went to training with the ball
shop with all the special force right
there a lot of fifth group team they
were there after training us they you
they trained Special Forces Iranian okay
those fifth group only fifth group not
seven group and it's interesting because
they are back in the 50s
he brought the CIA to train the SAVAK
exactly remember that because correct
sure that was when you Iran had a good
relationship with us do you train each
other when the Shah was yeah or - our
mission yes correct
from there they send us to Shiraz for
celebration 2500 onion history song was
there there's a cyrus degrade the
exactly pyre celebration correct
all these celebrities were falling God
didn't believe how much money they're
spent is great it was great but who work
hard with it
hmm so anyway I finished that and from
there they sent me to Kurdistan so I was
training Kurdish Iranian coolish with a
meta Massoud Barzani when I was I think
so
18 years old they can have I believe
that with him
nice nice guy when I spent all together
three and a half years then I came back
to Abaddon and my dad my uncle took me
to embassy actually consulates to try to
get a visa for me come America and
consulate said where you want to go as
I'm gonna go be as a pilot then say
you'll be pilot say yes and I'm going to
spend in a military he said seriously
yes sir then I'm gonna go Vietnam said
Vietnam we can't go Vietnam I said why
he said you know the US citizen I said
sir to kill the Communists you don't
need to be citizen
just send me I'll prove it to you you
were that determined you were that true
of a believer Oh God
yes Wow yes miss Pam yes Pat yes I came
to America in 1974 my brother my uncle
during California San Francisco San Jose
that the cop you know those days gas
stations was belonged to irani and most
of them now Laura Indian happy yes sir
yes it's okay no VD love it so I thought
I'm a good-looking man nice black hair
dark dark eyes I'm gonna have a good
with a blonde her that was wrong yeah I
was totally wrong so I lined up working
the gas station daytime and go college
after that I would from abroad three
years I said no no no this is not for me
because this could mean my adopted
country a lot of people here I want to
do something so nobody can tell me get
out and those days forty years ago
believe me that the people so different
so nicer than they are right now really
yes even though you were from Iran yes
oh the trip is so good the ass with
changes which you need stuff like that
helped me for many ways language of
bangs the stuff like that because it was
no such a terrorist stuff like that
everything changed everything changed
since I've been here so I I sign up a
sign - 1777
I came through army delay entry I sign
up for be Ranger and Special Forces I
remember I the recruit there are east 7
Thompson black guy good-looking guy on
all the medals so you be you're gonna be
Ranger Special Forces you're too small I
said don't join me by my size so ok you
pad my bag you wrote this stuff like
that so I took him up in my house
through interest my mom my brother's my
family supported me a lot yes go so what
do you have to do do it yes this is your
country you gotta do it you gotta
support it so nobody fought you join in
the US oh yeah they love supporting
everybody I think did you call your dad
back in Iran or no no I couldn't but the
story is anyway I finished all the
training when I was a 5 if you remember
those days we have a khaki uniform
beautiful I took the hop came to Travis
Air Force Base from the trigger
Greyhound came to Santa Clara
my dad came week before we arrived they
were so happy the grandma gave me kiss
stuff like that it was 1985 I believe
yes so he can visit me stuff like that
and I came back to Fort Bragg and my dad
went back to Iran and when I was citizen
also us came citizen became citizen 1984
yes when did you become citizen I 1980
got it so you joined the army with your
green card correct me too I was in the
Army Corps everybody's good how are you
without a notice you don't have to be
you need green card exactly not to be
sick correct a green card yes so 1985
your dad comes he visits and then you
going back to Fort Bragg my dad's went
back home okay am i back home is most of
stuff is in the book
ala Moana good long detail on it but
anyway but after six months 85 I heard
my brother mum my brother's my uncle
call me the staff to the fifth group he
gonna come home what's coming for what
what happened so they kill my dad
revolution kill my dad and my uncle was
a chief of DEA in Iran
Yusuf the [ __ ] so he take her my dad
everything I tried to go back to Iran
unit said no he cannot go even a steady
promise and you cannot go we don't let
you go because we afraid to commit
capture with her and put in the jail
over we kill you also
so about my mom my uncle my sister went
for believe my dad in Iran have a
ceremony you know how it goes would you
mind elaborating on how your dad was
killed I don't mind when I the way my
uncle told us define my dad naked body
they drop him off from fifth floor we're
still in the north of tehran safe and on
so to drop my dad behind our house it
was open open land there was no build up
yet so they find my dad naked and bloody
year the way my uncle told us I said god
I wanna have a revenge I have to go
after go do something to find out they
said take it easy now just through what
I have to do and I couldn't go I
couldn't go how much anger and rage do
you have at that time because you know
when I read about you and your dad you
guys had a lot in common you know you
said he saw you and he saw himself he
feared things that yes I don't have any
fear for anybody even even God because
God is not you have to fear for him
we're gonna love him he loves everybody
that's why I read Bible Quran and Torah
Bible everything they said even I'm not
Christian I'm a Muslim is all about love
so I I hold my anger so forgiveness I
cannot forget about it but forgiveness
is calming down during that moment that
moment also
yes because of always every time I pray
to God regardless what I go what I do it
doesn't matter what a good time a bad
time
ask him help me protect me that he does
so far he does I know I'm sure God does
for everybody not only for me the
angrier I have hold it because the
government from Iran to put everybody
down the make life miserable for poor
people in Iran since they cannot survive
sure let me ask you the event on when
they killed your father
it was the government that came in and
the neighbor said they saw some people
going into the house exactly that's all
back but my uncle asked the neighbors
that's my uncle told us that's what
neighbors saw a lot a couple people
going up and down up and down that's why
your dad threw it out from the window
inside outside the house why would they
go after your father though my dad was
very powerful man and he was a full-bird
color in the police department yes so
during siya or this is Khomeini only
Shah during how many he was retired
that's why I didn't like you because he
had a lot of connection be honest with
you I don't know why the hello
even today even today why it comes to me
why that's interesting to me because my
sister's husband my brother-in-law is
like a CEO max of a team on e so many
more voiceover Tomas is his father yes
okay so when they were living there of I
saw Bertie money was a very the Shah
loved the way of ice about you somebody
when he would give the news Ryan it was
an anchor we're very well known actor
with his voice you know you know yes so
when they were going through that era
and the revolution happened 78 79
correct how many was getting rid of
anybody that was linked to the Shah
generals I mean you know the story about
the arms being cut and all these other
things yes so you know that part of the
motivation of anybody linked to the shot
they were doing it I'm just surprised
that they still did it in 85 I'm just
surprised that that happened in 85 and
it kept continuing if I say they are
animal
or they have no education The Selfish
you want everything for themself to me
that's wrong
do you mind if we go back and spend a
little bit time in Iran with you Oxana
we went to all the weight up to the
fifth group in Fort Bragg but let's
let's go back because from there I know
we're gonna go into Black Hawk Down
we're gonna go to some of the
experiences right you know you jumped
out of a plane with as a parachute and
your partner jumped on top and you guys
were flying down to get killed right you
pulled the reserves you guys made and
his legs were shattered and you know a
lot of great stories yes incredible
stories you have there but I want to go
back to Iran I want to go back to when
you were living there right 60s 70s
today you turn on the TV when you think
about Iran you don't think about a place
to go for vacation you don't think about
a place to go hey honey let's go this
summer to Iran and take our family there
were back in the days you know how was
yes Frank Sinatra everybody would go to
concerts there parties there Elizabeth
Taylor was dating or VISAA he'd be the
ambassador there's a lot of things that
was going on back there right in the 70s
I think it was recognized as one of the
top three destinations for vacation
around the world you run out of all the
place all right
so paint a picture of what Iran look
like you know in the 60s and the 70s
from which you remember it was so opened
it was so open no I come tell you why
you here why are you drinking beer for
instance why you dancing why you listen
to music I read the Quran I didn't see
anything new or on they said it's big
Iranian they said you cannot drink you
cannot dance
I haven't yet I've found out three weeks
ago you don't believe it if I tell you
right now my cousin live in East Coast
Boston Massachusetts he read my book his
tenth couple book he is a brother in
Italy they said changes watch yourself
as a push button for what said the
article in a book everybody liked it but
your name is in the blacklist
my name is blackness okay what they're
gonna do kill me unbelievable because I
read the book Wow Bobby you don't hold
back in the book though you're not
holding back you're sharing your
thoughts your opinion I'm sure God I'm
sure
what you gonna do to me yeah you're not
know if they want to kill me I'm ready
come on
but Iran was open you run with it you
don't open up I hear back about it
around
Oh cover thumbs up awesome tell me tell
me stories from my dad but I would talk
about when I was covering you go is so
open
you see you drink your dance you have a
good time with your friends and you can
ask anything you want they bring for you
you were born that time I had obviously
you all know even in Abaddonn petroleum
company - Blanc was have belong to
government they have lot of clubs
in abuddin oh god you don't believe it's
beautiful people go with their like
Christmastime all o beautiful lights
people dancing with the family come
reservation like here the big hotel you
pay ten days before the table for you
all drinking wants any kind any kind
there's no no question about it
you know people ok people praying yes
people drink it yes I don't see what God
said don't drink but drink me I drink
one rate ok I don't need to get the
stupid so times were good so great a
time because you hear about you know the
music do you ever listen to the music
and go back to the time like do you
listen to goo goo yes goo God huge Moeen
del amico bass for hamburger them likes
you even English music water when I
worked by gas station my brother the
music Abba Orozco yes in Iran opposed
listen o understand the music what my
brother it was make me feel so good
you're almost good be honest with this
60 years ago well I came 40 44 years ago
that still that time was great if I won
when I was 10 years old
oh did you ever go to bender peleve 3 3
times you had to burn their back yes you
know they change your name I don't know
what it's called right I don't know yeah
but it was called Bandar pala way back
then correct by the parody Jessie a hawk
yep the are you still there or barely
would you go oh God ability on a ski of
course
yes there was a place my dad took me no
belly in the water he says jump in the
water so I jump in the water but it's
gasps Wow that's why I jumped and I
couldn't breathe the gas god I know it's
my ears he's laughing oh you're right
you're right but it builds so maybe we
would have G GAD you know liver outside
with the nice green and the salt and the
milkman you know Sarah Pole Santa Paula
Shane Braun I don't know you remember or
not used to go over there never seek
seek seek Shabab Oh God the the coin
they would know God salted water not the
putting the water content oh I stayed at
ten years old I was there till 10:00 but
I'm in October 78 baby so I was born
during the peak of cinema Xfire when it
happened happened that's when I was born
and cinema Rex wasn't about uh but uh
career let me ask you a question yes and
talked a little bit about since you're I
think it was your uncle that was the
chief of police or chief of intelligence
and about then what was your uncle chief
my dad was chief as chief was police in
Abaddonn undercover chief of police
about an undercover yes so he was there
one cinema Rex happened yes so let me
ask you a question the four hundred
people that were killed so exactly so
why don't you tell us what happened
cinema Rex well I was there you're not
insane I was in the house won't be
herded we because cinema to my Morehouse
about couple miles are the bicycle and
Police Department is next to cinema
quite a bit right yes right so somebody
has some problem lock the doors outside
so nobody could get out and as you know
those days they have a door like that
with a piece of metal you close it you
put the big chain inside and put a lock
in it so with the movie I start the lock
the whole door he wasn't one guy to guy
he was a few people did that they put
the gas around the theater and flame it
and exactly four hundred people died
it's correct until no I don't know they
couldn't find out who was it why did it
so they blame to people they said a
group so how many people said Suffolk
there's no one and the other side the
police did it right the police
department so they're saying who did it
that the police dude that Saavik dude
was
how many people dude who did it but that
was a disastrous moment when that's it
the blame was put on the Shah shocked
and protected innocent people died right
I just for me
it's a it's I come from that you know
whatever I've been in America for a
while I was in the Army I was proud to
be American but at the same time you
have an affinity to your homeland you
know here's something that before you're
born horik a bull curry a bony Iran like
I said many times of friends my body is
Iranian but my heart is America mm-hmm
okay because I want to be because this
country they give me opportunity to do
what I want to do sometimes I could not
reach it but at least they open the door
for me I will close to it I want to talk
about that one and the reason why people
like us come over here for better
opportunity your family or you decided
to come over here right but going back
to Iran you know you read stats they say
nine million people revolted okay that's
a stat you read about nine million
people is the biggest revolution of all
time in the history we've never had nine
million people revolt in all these
people show up and they're listening to
tapes of how meny who was living at that
time I believe in France cuz right
somewhere in Paris cuz they kept him
there he was an exile for a few who was
exiled twice at least right twice once
in the 60s once in the 70s and he was in
Paris for like metric yes so what caused
a revolution from your perspective your
family was involved somehow in politics
they were empowered they had some
contacts what caused the river how do
you go from the regime getting better
they're spending more money on education
he went from spending forty five billion
dollars I think from 63 to forty five
billion riyals and 63 to 67 in education
than he spent a hundred and seventeen
billion riyals from 68 to 72 then he
spent five hundred and forty billion
riyals from 73 to 77 things are going
good there's a million foreigners that
are working in Iran 1 million foreigners
that are working in Iran live in a life
with their wife with their kids and then
this revolution takes place what was the
cost for my opinion maybe I'm wrong the
people was close to show the light to
him as far as a shower
generals and they did not give the show
truth information people disrespect show
because they thought shot didn't help
them but they were wrong they thought
Khomeini comes they're gonna help him
better well who brought my opinion who
brought community to Iran community they
come by himself to Iran a CIA brother
community Iran to what to make it better
but no - CIA planted Khomeini so are you
saying
during because who was before Carter
Ford was before chorus right and it was
Nixon when I came here it was Nixon
presidency when you came here with Nixon
Nixon right God in 73 73 74 yeah he left
seven yeah so but Nixon had a good
relationship with the shop it's not like
they had a bad relationship I don't know
why America government and Iran
indicting America on Iran enemy I don't
see I don't see why enemy because they
did hostage okay
Iranian yeah it was wrong hold the
hostage people in Iran 1979 but Iranian
did not killed any Americans as far as I
know even today but we as American
soldiers we kill Laurie Runyon's lot of
Arabs Laura Afghanis to me I did too
because who's better than me me I'm in
the combat did Laura things to help me
in the combat everywhere my smile the
smart my smile saved me a lot in the
military and civilian life the calming
yes sir they put the gun on me as small
as a you know they took me places but I
came back clean but that moment I kill a
lot of people I hate to say that please
forgive me if I say that but no choice
no choice if I didn't kill the guys that
would kill me I survived I survived
survive I spent 11 years in the war
do you remember those moments vividly
those moments yes I remember
when I was active duty and Lebanon
active duty in Somalia and what I got
retired mm late 2000 I was Afghanistan
for 11 years I was with 10 special
forces group I was with deal with these
and our state department and yet some
run-ins with the Delta Force guys right
yes I built all the time yes I did a lot
of training the Far East together didn't
you do like over 100 missions in
Afghanistan I did more honest I did more
than hundred mission if I said in not
I'm not exaggerating it I did more than
three hundred three hundred combat
mission total total assault gun todo so
give me one of the ones that you know
stays with you till today I know let's
talk about Black Hawk Down when you
experienced that yourself the one this
one this one
our mission was honor after I came back
from work for FBI so mission was also do
5 9 6 v group our mission was human
Tyrion helped for the poor people in
their Somalia when the Black Hawk when
the people killed four Marines a few
remember that so drag him on the ground
so our mission change so our mission
change with a lot of patrol with the
theme in the market issues it was nasty
Oh God our God um we're gonna die every
day you're gonna die every day so a
black hole went down I was almost was to
to black house burned down we are
probably about 50 60 feet away from the
four second one we are at the west side
I believe oversight of a place we were
patrolling because I went to the house
as if it can be food helping they like
me I suppose not great Arabic but I
could get by okay goodbye partner for
God most of them never I never can
forget it and a friend of mine Tim
Martin he came he was a delta guy but SF
guy but what the Delta came by to
Okinawa Japan I met him then he went
back to Delta and he was in the Humvee
coming
through the town to support the other
guys support our Ranger guy and get RPG
hit him or between his leg
yes it's death run away right there and
great guy great guy known pretty much
good people right in front you when this
happens what happened not exactly front
of me it was about fifty fifteen fifty
twenty feet away fifteen feet 20 feet is
that well you know I I'm not gonna lie
to you exaggerated yeah well I see when
the RPG hit did you experience the whole
sound you can hear anything you're a
user
like I can't hit that much my left is my
left he airs is I get a hearing problem
I'm really worried but I don't like this
coming out all the time pretty bad is
still every everyday 24/7
I got ringing in my ears 24/7 so Black
Hawk Down going back to it so that
happens RPG hits his legs he's gone
right in front of you gone and a lot of
Rangers died over there I was so lucky
so lucky
who or what team was lucky then I came
back I spared 90 days how does nine days
a stay there we came back and a good
assignment DL I put the dl i dl I like
the yellow I am on an array yes okay yes
and I'm Monterey to deal I the
Linguistics school there used to be an
army base called fort or back in the
days now you go to dia like to learn a
language right in a you get shipped that
whole defense language school is a very
big everybody goes over there even
agencies go there and as a huge about
five five thousand troops goes over
there marine Navy or me a special forces
not that much because a special forces
right now they have the own schooling a
for brac six months really yes sir
but with this tandem advance to go one
year your Special Forces right now these
days they cannot go to the a-team unless
after graduate from a phase 1 phase 2
phase 3 they go to sere school there's
actual sere school that can break small
bones on you because they are to be a
POWs yes I did of the sere school 80 84
84 and serious rutter course
how hard was your school it's not that
long it's a short school today is a hard
you have to experience is they are
mentally and emotionally brain you ain't
really physically drained you yes did
you do the whole exercise of sitting in
the room and the sound and noises sound
loud the sound they beat you and you
have the you have you have to sign a if
it's something happened is you ask for
it's okay that's what we did that's why
I didn't know I would a lot of good
schools harder schools and I'm proud of
it because I prove to myself and now
these days people tell me what you'll
prove it I said have to prove anything
to you I'm retired I you know if I don't
know something about me I cannot carry
150 pound Rock stack anymore as you know
you know I carry atomic bomb cause say
them in my back in there Oh da 564 yeah
how was that when you were carrying it
ASAP it was a to team to group fifth
group and seven group task one patek one
group one battalion were the Satan and
Satan is very real bomb before sr-71 do
it's not like them before computer came
as you know company chem 91 92 so you
have to get that that solid bomb is 85
pound goes to Alice rock sack and when
you carry it you cannot walk a straight
if you walk like this and every person
of team carry your food sucks what water
you can put the water outside because
the other side nothing you can put
inside the rocks
how you feeling when you carry a nuclear
bomb on your bus is as bit it sucks
so water is a painful is a painful you
don't believe it that's what my bag miss
stop right now
it's painful with a lot of training I
did Forest a decline job I did - hallo
John but first halo jump I didn't do it
because my team I told my team sergeant
Bob Fleming the name is right here - I
can do it show me how to do it you can
Mooney John he was just tumble hundred
almost 120 130 miles an hour coming down
so fast then I had no experience a lot
of talk about them more because he first
say is right here right read the book
but tell me about the part where you got
tangled well that I found that one
unbelievable this one I get a team
member his name is was he died John
Murphy we go Thailand pulse' look
teaching Tai Royal Special Forces
training shooting at our house clear
stuff like that and because Thai people
they love to jump they love halo jump
you just go over there
if if they don't eat because they had no
money to rent the aircraft but we
support them along so we jump we let the
Thai people go first because there has a
Tennessee open the shoot fast so that
one comes get tangled or get killed so
they jump first after minute we would
hire 18 18 12 5 because if you go above
2 or 5 you get a word oxygen to 12 to
12,500 you don't have to blocks again
because you John be coming down fast so
Aires over there so we jump and open by
shoot 4500 I was doing good sunny John
Murphy he's it was the guy is a bad luck
all time he had ever damage on he do
something very very bad luck every time
he did four five accident so I was doing
coming to the drop zone
it was Airport I somebody hit me there
thank oh God his riser burned my neck
and my chute nine cell three silk claps
it was on I said god help me and he said
I I was very upset but I hold him in
mind both legs because he should came
down he could oh he couldn't do nothing
come on I swore to God that he says
changes changes please I don't know how
you know I was I was there because I
talk well a castle
okay that he knew he recognized my voice
so he said don't don't cut away don't
cut away if I would cut away we both was
dead both of you both yes both in your
initial reaction was to cut you were
initially think I was going to I was
going right here to cut away and open
him out herself
God said no one second a sword to god
one second while I hold the table so
tight and we're coming down fast
we were about 3,000 feet above the
ground I tried to land it in the grass I
couldn't make it I land in a runway he
landed God forgive me when he landed I
hit him my neck pain is a face almost
kill me
so I landed my back or broke four reps
and he broke his leg leg left leg yes
shattered no broke it
no she broke it born without yes I broke
my leg - I'll show you about that also
it was almost seven o'clock evening
daytime so that's what I'm saying god
bless america or god bless SF 2300 at
night one see one theory plastic took
him and us to Philippine from Thailand
from Thailand six hours drive you know
how much that cost how much a lot a lot
of money for civilians to do to me is a
great look at look at what I'm serving
that's why I love you guys
that's what I love guys so anyway a
freebie he was there for months I was
there for three days because doctor said
I can't do nothing about wrap that's
correct
you can't you can't have a surgery I
couldn't breathe for four weeks let me
ask you the black down I read one of the
stores were in the black down Black Hawk
Down right the pilot died when you guys
crashed pilot a pilot that and want him
one of your buddies died but you
survived it and there's a picture of you
right after right here the picture
Afghanistan 2008 yes we were doing
mission we clear the usually do missions
in a way yes I did I did a lot of
mission from from 2000 to 2010 I was
canister because you were doing a
civilian contract the civilian correct
so what happened to no weight when the
when the other Black Hawk went down the
carlos has almost advisor ided in
Afghanistan I see a lot of lake head
bones every time happened we have to go
we have to go survey click all the stuff
and give it to Senate to the FBI
analyzed it so what can I do I stay
using ok
after the find out what kind of the whys
using so they study it so in 2008 I was
working with as SF guys but it was no a
separately only me as a civilian advisor
we clear the 3540 caves they caves we
clear it wasn't cave that been alive and
build it no right because staffer made
it would have find what it was we poor
drew Mujahideen so stay there in the
valley called walled earnest nobody
could go with her that deep don't and
everything we did I did three weeks over
there today gonna come back go to the
main compound about with helicopter 45
business right or the cop three a
cocktail and they take us so usually the
they come from west take off from east I
don't know what happened that then they
landed from West and took her from West
we get up we were 13 people in the in
the helicopter and went up FBI GAO it
was with us to and Yaga FES as a NASA it
was as analyze all the IEDs that was his
job was so he came with us also
so when up those two hundred cops took
off
we were the 70 feet high we got hit I
said what's going on
coming down papa I said sit down sit on
sedum I was sitting down by face to the
pilot
everybody color all majors me two more
East seven women kept us so fast the
pilot and co-pilot very smart the shot
of the engine they had to because coming
down smashed on the on the ground roll
through roll over and the blade was
destroyed like a good picture also not
here but I got home we could open we can
open the door
I touched my hair my head awesome wet
blood all my face
Akita 34 times open the door and coming
out the enemy bought 100 feet over there
a fire after almost seven run by 1700
magazine that's a turtle turtle so they
were I guess I don't know how many I
kill or not I don't know I don't know
and and camp small campus we we crashed
right and above 50 feet but the champ
the army guy were the 10th Mountain
Division so the sooner they saw that
they came support us and the captain
Garcia remember his name he bandaged my
head right there survivors what were you
laughing man I'm surviving man I'm here
wounded but I'm life they were so happy
they after they took us to the small
medic over there they one guy and we
captain it was not such doctor so sooo
switch my head about 14 stages in the
head three full right here is already
established over here so they then send
me the medevac ask me another guy broke
his neck one guy died I believe it pilot
copilot because I keep the door open to
pull mouths because you couldn't get out
and pull him out so went to the base
they put me in the surgery room again
they killing me up they fix me very good
no question about I never forget that
and after that after three weeks
I remove me from there - can Phoenix
work for the special force again but I
was so afraid I was I don't want to give
him helicopter oh wow
so that stayed with you yes I was scared
every time I go to helicopter I would
just might fade out I couldn't I
couldn't I did though cuz I wanna I
don't want to be taken out but almost to
God even now if I'm flying with that big
commercial still hesitation wahoo
yes let me ask you the first time you
experienced being shot at how was that
scary is it extremely fast extra or you
very reaction based very I was another
section I was green ie D to the village
talk to police guy supporting him poor
guy standing next to me I was so lucky
sniper from hundred feet the house we
cleared after that he was going to kill
shoot me
I was nice to the policeman he killed
the policeman instead of me not by
accident I don't know what happened
god help me so he hit him or pull him
down over the grounds cover I called the
guys come on so after less than five
minutes we all went to the house the guy
was gone that's the first time I got
shot at yes
did you ever see any soldiers in the
heat of the moment panic and lock up oh
yeah froze up how many times did you see
it like what would and then would you
ask would they typically ask him to
leave or reposition him I turned get
down there scare I push him down
what would they do with them afterwards
would they send them back or there were
no chances until you got used to I am
I'll put him down and everything was
cooled down I could take him what do you
talk to him about what do you tell him I
said I told him I know you have a fear I
had the fear - but you have to fight the
fear you have to fight it for you can't
just froze and do nothing
get down cover and shoot back how's that
conversation is it an understanding
conversation or is it more like a dick
toriel dictate like hey you better do
this or else you get in ok the way the
way out the combat and
people what to do or force him or pull
the rank on there I just tell them about
experience correct them because if you
don't correct the guy right away he's
gonna die no good you gotta call him
right away did that bad habit out of his
body and give him motivation how many
times did you have to do that in your
career I did that's more than five six
times okay so not as many times so for
the most part right most people's
reaction was let me react fight back or
defense or I jumped in right right idiot
reaction correct so what's the first
time you shot at somebody and you felt
like I killed somebody do you remember
the first time for you the first time I
killed somebody he was in Rock not too
close to me I
I wouldn't say feel bad because I'll
protect myself and my colleagues yeah
it's nice to kill but the combat
situation totally different then you
kill somebody in the street I know but
the part I'm trying to ask you is was
there any sentiment or was it was like
you're trying to take my freedom away I
have to stop you before you do to me
that's right that's the mind that's it
okay that's me got it yes and I was with
general McChrystal yesterday I don't
know if you're number generator yeah
yeah yeah and he talked about the first
time he killed somebody and he said it
felt great because there was my job my
duty to protect my country and I had to
do it so the way he talked about it was
very much nonchalant it wasn't like oh
my gosh it's a big deal no it was a very
normal thing he talked about that that
happened in military talk all right
but a lot of guys in military they brag
about it oh I killed well you know I see
it a lot I listen but I don't say that I
said whatever you know I have a friend
of mine who was a delta right and he got
out he was Special Forces Delta and he
went all over and he will never tell the
horror stories and he won't brag about
it I never he is so uncomfortable too to
him it's very similar to what you're
saying right now when you went one time
did you start etching it you're like I
have to go again and again and again and
again and because you're like Haiti
nothing really happened it's almost as
if you wanted to see more action
will you driven by that action no I
didn't ask for it I'm gonna go get get
my CIB or give my medal for us the cure
no never done that everybody SF knows
who I am
I don't worry patches stuff like that
all this to force me when I go calm even
even now when I walk someplace I'm
always conscious 360 even today even
today
what do you sit in the restaurant you
seen a specific place in a restaurant I
will not see it in the front or in the
middle I see it behind my back I'm
bagging the wall back against the wall
god that's amazing how even I go even I
was top 2 Humvee with the two for ease
of fifty Cal we didn't have those block
Humvee coming up you know what those
covered no no we didn't have that when I
was Afghanistan we didn't have it but
always on watching myself back in over
360 watching because I was I was
training cars I detailed we have the
convoy take their students to the range
fire there's a combat combat zone going
back to the 18 part what was it like
being part of the a team first of all I
mean how does somebody become part of
the a team I know Special Forces you
have to be you can't just say I want to
go be Special Forces there's a extreme
training process Ranger School is its
own school airborne schools of only cool
series as its own Special Forces
how long Special Forces eight weeks or
12 weeks the selection is one month
after your selection you have to you
have to know your mo sa MOS depends the
MOS and the longest MOS in a spray force
a very crude account medic that's the
one where they say you day they stab out
your heart and they say you have to make
sure the cow doesn't die goat goat goat
goes via yes I was manic before but I
couldn't handle the medical terminology
I couldn't I couldn't pass it I was
afraid so I change my almost 280 it was
used to be 11 Bravo 11 the tool Bravo
weapons heavy light and heavy you ask
you about them a team a team is a place
not for everybody when you reach the
selection finish your mo SS you come to
a team as a young a 5f4 team sergeant
trained you you have to listen with
these
saying to you you just don't go depends
depends the situation is you just don't
go to combat shooting no he testing you
so each mo SS is a team they speak
foreign languages everyone every one of
us every one
they speak one language is like Farsi
Arabic Chinese and those languages like
v group most speak Farsi
Dorrie Arabic because we belong to me
least seven group was a speaking spanish
italians
and third group you speak Sahul is from
Africa and Arabic because they belong to
Africa ten group the most speak Russians
German French those people speak that
yesterday and for first group everybody
speak Chinese not everybody like one
Chinese want to speak Tagalog want to
speak Thai want to speak yes just words
if any ancient languages those languages
yes the good thing about a team is
nobody comes to you as a team member to
of man supervise you they give you
opportunity to prove yourself whenever
you ask me changes I want you watch this
book for me for 10 hours it's not to
come here I'm drinking whiskey or coffee
and don't pay attention the task you
gave me to do that so that's good about
a team everybody understand everybody
helped each others in the team every
watching job we have one captain one one
officer and we have ten enlisted the e8
team sergeant he runs the team and
everybody has to listen to him even
captain warm officers so rank doesn't
matter in the 1880 no I like that that's
what we don't because they don't want
pause right no they call me changes
that's why to call me changes and a team
you guys had mustaches you didn't dress
up the same as everybody else
not anymore they used to be like that
girl but now we need different countries
you see it yes we grooming standard we
bear long hair like an Afghan
I was Africa I was a fifth group Middle
East we do a stuff to blend in what
we're coming back used to be four years
ago but not because they change it but
what are your different countries yes
that you don't understand you know the
biggest difference you notice from
Special Forces Iran training versus
Special Forces here training whatever
the difference what's the difference are
different is the better equipment here
equipment equipment got better classes
better technique that's what we learned
from fifth group Laura we have lower
American technique philosophy Laura
American philosophy technique in Iran
when I was going when I was being
recruited to Special Forces 18 Delta
right fifth group which was right down
the street rightly to six right my
colonel was Colonel peacocks at the time
and full bird and right I went there
they said you know best thing you want
to do is go talk to some other Special
Forces and to come to them yesterday I
don't understand that in ischium like
listen you want me like I was like I'm
gonna be a super soldier I work out I'm
strong I'm gonna be I speak languages I
was the typical cocky to a 19 year old
right look I'm gonna come and help you
take over the world go talk to other
Special Forces so I started talking to
him so many times the topic of marriage
came up exactly so I'm like why are you
talking to me about marriage you would
say a private so soldier let me ask you
that was an e4 at the time do you ever
want to get married and have kids and
have a family
yeah of course never become Special
Forces reason I said why and they would
say just it's not gonna work out I'm on
my fourth marriage I'm on my third
marriage I'm on my fifth marriage I've
been married five times I've been
married three times to do so so you've
never been married until you were 62
correct and you said at 62 you met a
Native American woman who you cook your
is your white now and he said I think
that's 62 it's time for me to settle
down
that's four how do you view marriage
okay people like me in a Special Forces
you're always deploy and you leave your
wife behind nine ten months a year and
kids she understand but not that much
she get tired of it because women need
the man be close to her maybe not 24 a
day hours a day but has to be close to
family especially the kids
so a special forces unit is hard nine
months is a long time long
I was going 11 months a year so you're
on the road on the internet for yes sir
deployed yes you just got married yes
congratulations oh so how would you know
if you don't mind me asking I'm 68
you're 68 yes sir - ten years ago you
were still going and doing attend one
Blackhawk down that but yes I was I was
hardcore
you were 58 yes I was hardcore I was bad
oh could not touch me I'm not kidding
you Wow I was at the beard that long I
sure my beard I saw the picture I saw
the problem I was getting blood all over
your head on the picture it see and
that's right after the whole thing oh
yes I did I did I was jogging a calm
Wayne oh man changes are you pretty
sentimental guy are you pretty are you
the guy that gets emotional and you go
back thinking history thinking family
thinkin Iran or not really you're pretty
emotionally I am emotionally yes I'm a
sensitive to what who people tell me
you're terrorists
I tell people tell me I said this
terrorists fight for your freedom and
still fight in and fight from us my
freedom also it's very obvious those
comments bother you the camo comments -
oh God it's called me camel jockey they
call me in Ward a first of four the lot
a lot cuz you guys build your oh yeah so
well I was good boxer - since 10:54 than
15 years
I just forgiveness for me is key because
I just
if I get fight upset myself I just
killing myself doesn't worth it
how do you view the show what I think
what's your what's your memories owner
just idea of the show what do you think
about the Shah was good he went too fast
put it this way the Shah first death had
one bag of gold give it to the his
general the passing out but the end
nothing left what I'm saying by that
that means he trusts everybody but he
did not listen to people to have more
knowledge than him who should he listen
to any specific names he told him
something about the Revolution he didn't
listen to him about know any no that's
what I'm saying that's my point is you
have to take home anymore seriously says
he's not he's too old he's gonna stop
we don't necessary but so he should have
listened there he shoot inocent
do you think he got a little too
confident a little too confident about
what was happening in Iran like who
confidence the interview would be BC do
you remember that the blue-eyed people
the brown-eyed people's are teaching the
blue-eyed people's something is that
well we really we are not teaching
something the blue-eyed people have to
wake up wake up to from the complacency
for this topper in which they put
themselves by taking maybe too many
sleeping pills and he said Iran in the
next 5 10 15 20 years is gonna be one to
top 5 empires in the world it was wrong
was wrong it was because he was too
confident see you have you have to walk
into it say he didn't take that approach
what should he have done what Khomeini
say him that he listened to Majid what
should he have done to how many great he
should not bring in from any party he
didn't mean how many back didn't know he
got exiled he got foreign country
brought brought him back
sure got exiled that's why he shouldn't
left the country he shouldn't have left
him know he know he gonna die Shah
should stay in Iran even if he dies
every died he Dean died his country he
died in Asia sure should not left the
country his son right now with a DC DC
right what do you think about him I
don't he's a smart guy what he's doing
he just talks what should he be doing
he's my opinion he should grasp people
like old guys like you same military
they are here exactly America get
together have a good plan keep the good
plan to build Iran again do you think he
has to listen to the older people or
they're not cuz you know sometimes the
older people are afraid of giving them
direct feedback because they're kind of
at the phase of life is good it's about
forgiveness my grandkids I want to play
the vast difference situation
forgiveness forgiveness you give
forgiveness to people that you know same
ya know that I do but you don't give
forgiveness to those barbarian Iran and
forgiveness to people Arab from Saudi
Arabia okay they killing each other
the killer Iranians to those for
give this is not forgiveness those pill
has to be you believe that yes so you
you believe that something needs to be
done to the people that cost a half a
million lives of Iraqis and Iranians do
but they believe it and you think he can
lead something like yes because he
killed half a million Iranian yes Saddam
Hussein he was another most people we
killed him you know who find Osama
saying mmm fifth group and some Delta
guys do you know how many how much money
brand-new adult hundred bill dollars in
the boxes dub tougher back I seen it but
I couldn't touch it it wasn't belong to
me let me ask you one time I'm sitting
down talking to a guy and he said do you
know why America has to be very careful
when they go against the extremists in
the Middle East I said why he says
because Christians believe in
forgiveness they don't believe in
forgiveness they're gonna retaliate so
if you're going against somebody like
that you can't play that same game with
them does that make sense like you're
saying oh it's okay let him go it's okay
forgive them it's okay forgive them it's
okay forgive them meanwhile they keep
attacking attack and infiltrating do you
think Reza that his son Reza Pahlavi
you're saying okay one go and talk to
the older generals and bring them
together there's some here in the u.s.
that are still around not a lot of them
some of them are solvable yes if you are
gonna infiltrate don't you need to isn't
it gonna get ugly before it gets better
like I don't think Iran is gonna be a
peaceful revolution if it ever goes back
relation people from Iran I'm talking
about grab something is right I'm very
hard to them let it go you know how many
those more or less presidents took the
money out from Iran brought to America
that family still money went to Venice
Sula the richest people in the world yes
so you saying the name that I'm thinking
yes it's sixty five billion dollars yes
that's exactly him his sons have the
money
Iraq correct took your money my money
even I'm not living in what you do what
can you do with that today they should
stop them even our son should listen to
young people like you educated people
educated like you listen man those
people cannot breathe
you know when I came here and Donna was
seven to month seven to man that I was
about to say 79 you took the words out
of my mind
thank you my dad waited till 89 and when
he came it was already done it was too
expensive but today from 7 - men to
14,000 - man is unbelievable cuz get a
benefit they're gonna benefit so you do
think there's a possibility to create
always possibility always possibility to
move better places you know we have a
lot of your onions that watch value
tainment great from Iran underneath Oh
underground say I'm in Iran right now
I'm a younger generation right what
should I be doing like if I'm watching
this ain't this guy kind of makes sense
what what should I be doing if I'm a 17
18 19 20 year old over there
don't give up get friends together trust
each other have a good plan because
these days technology awesome you can go
to Google find out escape find a
shooting technique you're going that
deep so you're talking militia yes
that's how far you're going why not when
I spoke to Reza Pahlavi one time the Sun
right and we were in DC at an Italian
restaurant we had a meeting together
with him for a few hours
he said his plans were a peaceful
revolution do you think it is possible
for Iran to have a revolution to be
peaceful
how can be peaceful if remember so walk
was only in Iran correct now look at
every person in a Khomeini's revolution
they die for money so they get paid good
so who suffering those people students
woman kids to me it cannot be peaceful
because it cannot be peaceful has to be
something destroyed at least 50 60
thousand people get killed one day in
whole Iran only Tehran then people put
the weapons down
see that's why I don't think it's gonna
it's gonna happen anytime soon because
someone has to take the responsibility
of 50 60 thousand lives and whoever it
takes that responsibility to fifty sixty
thousand live you're not necessarily
hero to do something Noli situation to
it yes but it's not going to be hero
things because killing people is no good
my opinion but when time comes you want
to change your revolution as you know
history
I didn't see I didn't read any history
revolution was peacefully yeah your
opinion on Khomeini what is your opinion
who mean I know you said something where
you had a hard time with the religious
zealots my dad told me told us he wasn't
open-minded
do not trust these priests mullahs at
all I don't tell you that
oh yes or together Wow at all do not
because there are no real people that's
why I'm not a religious man I don't you
know I respect everybody religious yes I
do you were the first Muslim special
force yes nobody
yes Korea the first Muslim special for
the first month Iranian yes Iran I'm a
first Iranian Muslim American I'm
American for this ok in a team spray
forces and I'm a first American history
green beret staying a team two years no
break that's amazing to me
no brainer to me that's long-standing
how long you want nobody yeah I broke
every bone my body I make sense why you
didn't get married because I was gone I
love this country I love the people I
work with that I never put him down
I got they put me down a couple of on
bath but you learn how to make friends
with them oh yeah your opinion on
Khomeini think about that this guy was
80 years old come to Iran even cannot
talk I see his pictures many times
videos how much he knows about politics
only thing he knew my opinion I am wrong
for religion okay
he knows okay you can read a lot about
religion give yourself educated these
days how did 9 million people follow
though because the for stem the force
people force nine million people to go
out there I mean I remember a speech he
gave he said Iran has so much money the
Shah so rich if you make me the your
president your leader I'm gonna give you
free rice free food free drinks free
house free this free that how but he
said it and they fell for it but because
because the Forsett people like I said
every other Iranian the undercover cop
maybe I'm wrong but you have a lot they
get money more or fraud a lot of fraud
in Iran you know it here too but
different way not a fraud in Iran I
haven't been there's 44 years you
haven't gone in for 44 years
yeah I didn't you go there to the
embassy right after Jimmy Carter when
your 40s but it was the three weeks yeah
but you went to Tehran for three weeks
nobody know me that right you were spy
when you call right yeah you want an 88
what you're you an 81 right you an 80
cool the MSE embassy right when I okay
this is story when I read the letter to
President Carter can I read the letter
yeah I want to read the letter you wrote
to President Hartley's dear President
Carter my name is sergeant Cheng Isla he
Jie and I am an Iranian native servant
and Special Forces Fort Bragg North
Carolina please give me permission to
choose an a-team and deploy to Iran to
freed American hostages I know the area
well and used to play soccer at the
stadium across the street from the US
Embassy with your approval and support I
am sure I can come up with a plan that
will succeed please don't say no that's
why dance I almost think I truths I did
that's why that the way they're living
longer and they said let me get back to
you and let us see that's what you just
like that when I was like the when I was
a contractor when I spot the bin Laden
2002 war it went to Tora Bora he came
back to NBC it was it was offering 25
million dollars I don't care about that
money you know he's he's around here
what we get back with you because we
don't want it we didn't want to rid of
the bin Laden that time 2002 we had a
mission in Afghanistan not only bin
Laden lot of thing we had to be close to
Iran close to other bhaijaan close to
Russia because Afghanistan country is a
very very important land for all for our
interests even erroneous you said CIA is
the one that influenced Khomeini and
I've read that many many different
places you're not the first person that
says this right isn't CIA linked to
Carter at the time and I know it's two
different agencies but still commander
in chief at the time was Carter what's
your opinion on President Carter
President Carter is I met him personally
I was his a detail in the Sudan door for
his pre calm guy he is smart very smart
brilliant very smart
so I like about him
is not rushing to go kill people - okay
do it thinking do you think a part of
that the fact that he moved slow also
caused Iran to get out of control
correct you know that part where he
didn't help the shot as much as he Kris
moment he left on December 31st that's
right New Year's Eve he left six days
later the revolution started example
like President Obama pull the troops out
from where all too soon
Isis came you don't do that look at how
much costs US taxpayer money for this
stupid war you think is so Carter had
some influence with the Iranian
Revolution fallen for loaning the Empire
falling after this yeah did he influence
that I think so yes I think so he did
the problem was Shaw he should've left
the country like I said before he did
and he wasn't getting any help though he
asked for a while though nobody helped
him because CIA America was the Iran
revolution change something because the
more it happens the more control they
have over oil your eyes is more stable
it seems like the more stable Iran is
the less control people can have over
Middle East and OPIC and politics all
that stuff you got it so the more issues
there's there the easier it is to be
able to control oil prices all these
other things correct but I mean look
it's a it's a very fascinating topic to
me because again I was born I lived
there for ten years I'd like to one day
be able to take my kids back to Iran for
them to say here's Caleb Idaho jet is
what your daddy okay here's the school
good baby right here's the park you saw
hand shot right roll the skateboard and
fell on my back that's right here's a
you know caspian sea band up a levee
this is nice to go eat caviar as you
know here's I don't want to be able to
the only I hope someday yeah trust me
son I hope someday to I hope someday to
and I think today with the tools we have
on social media I think it's more doable
today than ever before
yes in was 2012 where Iran was number
one in the world with women
bloggers Oh women bloggers writers so
the amount of influence they have with
writing sharing their opinions today
they're on Instagram they're active it's
higher than it's ever been before but
we'll see what will take place again if
you're watching this we're gonna put a
link of his book here I could literally
I wrote the book I read the book on a
plane and I'm just like yeah I'm gonna
try to see if I can read a few pages and
I just want that I just could
put it down the first first five pages
just sucks you in to stay for the rest
of the book it's so much fun stories
that he's experienced some of them are
tragic stories but some of the
experiences had the way it's written
very very well-written we'll put the
link below for you to go read it send me
a tweet I want to know what you took
away from this interview if you're from
Iran send me a message on Instagram or
Twitter and let me know what was your
biggest takeaway from watching this
interview if you are from Iran and if
you haven't subscribed click on a link
below to subscribe to the channel thank
you so much for your time thank you for
coming and earlier thank you thank you